sexual reproduction is strongly anchored
to what's called the autonomic arousal
system whereby there's excitement and
then but it can't be too much excitement
because it's too much excitement it
actually inhibits the sexual response
believe it or not the orgasm response in
both men and women is driven by the
stress system of the body but it has
this positive valence it's a lot of
dopamine afterwards there's a return to
below baseline levels of energy and then
it repeats right at whatever frequency
that couples
for them dopamine is strongly released
in anticipation and during sex and and
then afterwards it plummets and there's
another molecule called prolactin which
skyrockets prolactin actually sets the
refractory period at least for males sex
can't happen again learning to toggle
back and forth between excitement and
anticipation but never hitting that
absolute extreme excitement is a very
useful thing don't ever hit the ceiling
in that way you maintain motivation you
maintain excitement and learn how to
toggle back and forth